hello there I'm gav I'm Dan we're the
slow-mo guys I very much enjoy Dan a
video that is rooted in science but the
end result of slo-mo footage is your
stupid face
this is the slower guys welcome to the
channel if you're new uh that's what we
do we'll be filming the effects of
GeForce in slow-mo on the human face
there's a face but obviously an
expensive fighter jet is out of the
question on our budget so instead we've
got our very old pre-used cheap
trampoline couldn't even spring for a
new one eh I don't even know where the
cover's got for goodness sake no mouse
traps or balloons on it this time though
that was a good pun I almost missed it
yeah you nearly did I almost let that go
by yeah we'll also be trying something
slightly different with the Phantom
today so let me show you that setup all
right so for the first shot ideally
we'll have you holding the Phantom while
you're falling back on the trampoline
and I'm basically going to build a
little handheld version of it so we'll
take the top handle put it on the side
and on the other side we'll put this
little hand grip battery we could
probably put underneath
that so I think the final setup looks
something like that and then you can
just hit the old trigger on the back
there it's still not light it's not as
light as a mirror it's still a 4K
Phantom it's still some heft all right
Priority One yeah there's a lot to think
about probably one
don't let that hit you in the face
because Dent your head
if you know what I think you should do
it because if it hits your nose maybe
it'll just put it back into position
cheers B cheers for that carry on
they too uh try not to let go so it
bounces off and smashes on the floor and
then you got you know framing uh Focus
that's all preset but you know there is
a case of there might be some pivoting
and a fourth try and Trigger it within
five seconds
I like that you've uh
put my face above the six figure camera
uh I have actually yeah as it goes
oh cheers I appreciate that and I hope
you do the same for me
Maybe
depends how I felt on the day you know
you're doing all the filming of this are
you excited no no
I mean I'm nervous
okay I've got it nice all right come
over here with me
this is my Phantom Shuffle
falling through space and time you feel
like you've just been Let Go by Sandra
Bullock
oh
it's like you aged about 15 years
that's what it looks like for me falling
Six Feet Under
that's great
well done me excuse me fresh bat
do you reckon you could do a mother
where your eyes stay open yeah I just
haven't been thinking about it no I I
haven't asked you to yeah I'm just
giving you more to think of it I'll try
that just got my bounce a little bit
wrong do you remember when um we had
Andy Bell put a freaking Phantom on his
head
and jump over the pool
oh yeah now that was insane God that was
the heavier one in this as well wasn't
it it was a mirror I think it was
lighter still on your neck still I've
got both my arms holding this look at my
framing's perfect you've nailed that
look at that you're a blind camera
lips are all flopping there's even good
info on the up bounce no honestly I'm
not trying to do it
no I'm fine so now switched to this
absolute unit of a 200mm lens to get
nice and close on your face
perfect ass drop
I don't know
what noises
it's got I've got to do the noises to it
it's like it helps my jowliness that's
how tight it is that is tight
see uh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
God what's up you got a new profile
picture
I'm like a goo from like Fallout smooth
skin
cool right before you've gone feral yeah
oh you can get that slightly more in
focus
and also if I track you better we'll be
able to see that take
I just quite like the uh going out of
the frame bit though to be fair and then
coming back through the train it just
adds comedic value leaving us human
returning as ghoul yeah I think what the
thing is we've been aiming the light
when you're SAT but it's lower than that
but you're sinking so far down that we
need to be lighting your knees basically
okay
backdrop
I don't know what's going on
I started
attract you some of the way back up too
oh
that's just a brief moment in time were
you just elongate my bottom lip just
goes so low it really does you want to
go for a bit of full frontal hard
frontal
well you've been jumping up and down in
a very hot room for the last hour yeah
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
God he's so deep in there you went
really deep I've got an app to track G's
so we can see what kind of G's I'm
pulling when I land and jump what kind
of G's have you been feeling
um I would have said about four maybe
five tops but judging by how it looks on
camera with my face and everything it's
got to be more than that feel like it's
more than four gravities on your mug on
my lip alone it's like so it's got to be
pretty Savage
[Music]
oh jeez did a good job of tracking me
there oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah for a split second I was hitting
like fighter pilot G-Force there I guess
so but like just for a split second like
the level of cheese where you actually
need a high speed camera to see and not
like a sustained
yeah I suppose it's not the same thing
is it yeah so wait does that mean that
if I'm on a planet that's pulling that's
like seven G's yeah I walk around like
this yeah you're probably right you'd be
walking around people sagging down your
eyes sort of
lip hanging off
well that was actually some pretty
fascinating and pretty goofy footage
which well I think that was the goal
hopefully you enjoyed that video make
sure you subscribe if you like slow-mo
and we'll be right back you're right
there yeah just just doing my bounces
make sure you subscribe if you like
slow-mo uh
I messed up
[Laughter]
you have to give me a minute
God